but first up he is the mayor of South
Bend Indiana and author of shortest way
home 1 mayor's challenge and a model for
America's future mayor Pete Budaj edge
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
well you're blowing up man you blow it
up feels good yeah I bet you it does now
did I get the name close yeah of course
that's it
I read its boot edge edge you gotta put
a judge yeah just like it looks let's
call you Pete okay so yet you are
blowing up I mean wow I must admit a few
months ago I was just you know who's
this guy youngster I'm not gonna ask you
the age question because first of all
I've heard you answer it now and I don't
think it's relevant you're 37 I know
people who know if you're 27 I would say
yes that's do young I mean legally it's
due yet but 30 I've know people who are
37 super mature you're one of those
people I've known people who were 80 who
are still idiots people are humans
they're not numbers correct and the same
would apply to Joe Biden yeah okay so
but why are you suddenly rising in the
polls well I think part of it is that
people are looking for something
completely different and you know we're
in this moment I really believe that oh
we got it that well in a way we did
right I mean each each election in many
ways produces somebody who's the reverse
of what we just had and you could argue
that it doesn't get more different from
this president than a laid-back
intellectual young gay mayor from the
Midwest
right I mean we hear the stories about
you like you found a book he wanted to
read but it was not translated from the
Norwegian so you learned Norwegian I
don't know what Trump is but you're the
opposite of that
I mean he's fat you're thin he's old
you're young you went to Afghanistan he
dodged the draft right there's a lot of
very different people you're very
different so how do you beat them well I
think that's part of the idea I mean
look the paradox here is in order to
beat Trump we got to run a campaign
that's not all about Trump you know the
more it's about him I think folks at
home are gonna be saying okay who's
talking about me don't get me wrong you
got to punch back when you're punched
you gotta correct
lies when he tells lies but then we've
got to move on very quickly to how our
ideas actually cash out in everyday life
because when we do that we win look at
the political trajectory of Obamacare
the Affordable Care Act in 2010 when I
was first getting into elected politics
it was a toxic issue for Democrats by
2018 it was the winning issue for
Democrats and I think the reason is
people saw what it meant in their
everyday lives and we got to be willing
to talk not just at the highest level
about our values but at the ground level
about how following our values cash is
out and instead a lot of the time we've
been stuck at that middle level which is
about the policy designs before we
really win the day either for the values
that motivate those policies or for the
results that come from those policies so
you're still the mayor of South Bend
that's right but are they mad at you
cause you're not there a lot now because
like well you're a senator and you're
running for president no big deal
because they don't do anything anyway
look but I you know I hear you say look
I am actually in charge of a city I got
to do stuff every day
what's going on with that yeah well most
people running for president have very
demanding day jobs and you know the City
South Bend is is that is my day job and
people at home thankfully haven't you do
tend to it yeah I have to I mean you
know at the end of the day I'm like
you're annihilated or the out of this is
work what if the sewers back up we have
phones we got the you know I mean you
know a lot of the work that I do
obviously is is guidance policy but also
you know one of the reasons I'll be on a
red-eye is to get back home quickly and
tend to some things
so okay so you're from the part of the
country that the Democrats just really
want to win back I don't know if Indiana
will be in play used to be yeah that's
right could it be could be it's not dead
well in stone right that these states
have to be conservative man fact there's
a very deep progressive tradition in the
industrial Midwest okay but you know
they used to ask this question after
9/11 why do they hate us but I want to
ask it about Republicans in their
attitude toward Democrats yeah why do
they hate us well why is the D so toxic
that we automatically write-off 25
states well first of all we got to look
at the media diet right I mean not only
the Twitterverse but if you're on a diet
of Fox News and some of this
conservative radio you may literally
never even hear our perspective and and
I think there's an echo chamber it's one
way you got to go on Fox News yeah which
I was really surprised to discover I was
I was the first out of the candidates to
go on on Fox News Sunday but if I didn't
a lot of viewers would have never heard
what I had to say so I think we got to
penetrate there I also think sometimes
there's a sense of condescension coming
from our party fairly or unfairly I
think a lot of people perceive that
we're looking down on them and if we
allow that content to continue it's
going to be a real problem
look if a wealthy coastal liberal
professional goes up to to a guy pumping
gas in South Bend
maybe maybe wearing a one of those red
hats and said you know you're voting
against your economic interests guys
gonna say he's gonna say so are you or
if he ever VIII says you you have white
privilege well that's that rubs people
the wrong way
I mean look white privilege is real and
we first took about these issues but we
can't paint people into a corner where
they have nowhere to go but the far
right that that's how radicalization
works we need to invite them onto the
right side of history not by I mean
don't get me wrong we're gonna give no
quarter to things like white nationalism
that helped animate this presidency in
this campaign but I also think we have
an obligation to be speaking to things
like the loss in a sense of belonging I
mean exactly the kind of thing that
opens people up to radicalization
whether it's here at home or in places
like the Middle East
let's breakfast yeah exactly and you
know this the same desire for belonging
that might motivate you know an auto
worker in the mid
his career who's finding himself
disrupted by modernity is also the sense
of belonging that explains that the fear
of a dreamer who's afraid they might not
belong and what they feel to be their
own country or a transgender kid in high
school we just has to go to the bathroom
like everybody else I mean if we get it
right then talking about this sense of
belonging can actually knit us back
together instead of watching it turn
into something that makes us so
vulnerable to being divided against you
just said transgender going to the
bathroom how often does that really
happen is that a real problem several
times a day to make them applaud I'm
talking about the people who are going
to elect the next take care of people
I'm just saying you mentioned you have
like eight minutes here yeah and out of
that of all the things you mentioned
that thing I'm saying we're talking
about how do we win back those people I
don't know if that's the thing we want
to accent it may be a very issue what
we've got to do is we got to paint a
picture of life in the future that my
generation is living into so one of the
reasons I talk a lot about what the
world will look like in 2050 for that's
the year I would get to the current age
of the current president and you know
you're a millennial yeah okay so here's
the thing now I don't want to generalize
cuz I do shows all around the country a
lot of Millennials come and they know
that this is not a safe space so they're
not all fragile but but in general
they're fragile and that is some you
don't think so I mean this is the
generation that provided the bulk of the
troops and the wars after 9/11 we're not
talking about that's how many percentage
if we're talking about the the people
I'm talking about people who need cry
rooms and trigger warnings and safe
spaces there Harvard had an issue a
couple of weeks ago
Ronald Sullivan he's a brilliant
professor he's a Dean they're African
American who is defending Harvey
Weinstein and there was a big protest
these are Harvard students who don't
understand that everybody gets a lawyer
in this country they're saying we don't
want to get our diploma from someone who
was this closely associated with the
violating the meet two principles no
matter what his reason no matter what
his
reasons Harvard students don't
understand maybe they just think that's
the right place to protest that what
they see as going into the the
Toleration of sexual harassment but
isn't the principle that everyone gets a
lawyer in America more important you
still have a lawyer but then when a show
when he shows up you can also raise your
voice to protest what he represents
that's a whole idea of free speech and
vigorous debate I'm all for that
look I don't know if it's debatable that
everybody gets a lawyer
I agree everybody ought to get a lawyer
sure but the decision is you know to
what extent do you invite those people
or appear to be conferring honor on them
so let me ask you one final question
you've said that you think the left
should reclaim faith yeah that's curious
to me you're such an intellectual guy I
guess I never understand how faith mixes
in with that you know I always identify
faith as the purposeful suspension of
critical thinking look and you're you're
a brilliant critical thinker how do you
align that look I believe in reason I
believe in enlightenment values and I
also believe that reason has limits now
don't get me wrong I mean I think
especially in our party but using no
reason there's a better answer look
maybe you think you got it all figured
out no no I'm not saying that neither do
I and I don't know the end when I don't
know an answer I don't make up a story
the important thing is to recognize like
God doesn't belong to a political party
I mean some of these themes right God
freedom patriotism right these are not
things that that one party should be
able to claim but that's how it's worked
out we made it sound like the only way
to apply for example religious values
and politics would be through the lens
of the religious right when when I go to
church what I hear a lot about is
protecting the downtrodden and standing
up for the immigrant and being skeptical
of Authority sometimes and making sure
you look after the poor and the prisoner
I mean to me that that's the sort of
thing that the religious left often
without much attention has been arguing
for for my whole lifetime the same with
freedom you know this theme that we've
allowed our conservative friends to
monopolize as if government were the
only thing that could make you on free
the reality is you know your neighbor
can make you on free your cable company
can make you on free being poor
absolutely very unfairly so let's talk
about freedom to now
just freedom from and the way that
you're free to start a small business if
you have health care the way that you're
free to to marry the person you love if
the law of the land is that a county
clerk can impose their religion on you
so whether we're talking about faith
whether it's freedom whether it's
patriotism and we need I think we need
to assert that often those very values
can point us in our progressive
direction and that no party ought to
have them not lay on them mayor Pete
thank you very much
[Applause]
you